[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur l'antenne de France 24 je suis ravi
de vous retrouver c'est le journal de
l'Afrique 12 minutes pour s'informer sur
le continent voici nos titres ce soir à
la Une le verdict de l'attentat de
Grand-Bassam en Côte d'Ivoire les
familles des victimes l'attendaient 11
accusés et cops d'une peine de prison à
vie les cerveaux de l'attaqueuse
n'étaient pas présents de violeurs inter
communautaires ce coutent au jour le
Soudan du Sud selon les Nations Unies on
compte 166 morts au bas mot depuis le
mois d'août des tensions locales à
l'origine elles se sont ensuite
propagées à plusieurs provinces et puis
cette très bonne nouvelle pour les
Éthiopiens les vols commerciaux ont
repris entre la capitale Alissa Beba et
la région rebelle du Tigré théâtre vous
le savez d'une guerre sanglante pendant
deux ans l'émotion vous le verrez était
au rendez-vous
bienvenue sur notre antenne après un
mois de procès le verdict de l'attentat
de Grand-Bassam et donc tombé en Côte
d'Ivoire de la prison à perpétuité pour
11 des accusés condamnés entre autres
pour acte de terrorisme et assassinat en
fuite ou en détention au Mali les
cerveaux de cette attaque qui avait fait
19 morts honteux été jugé par contumace
les précisions de Sadia manjo depuis
Abidjan
seul 4 des accusés étaient présents
aujourd'hui il s'agirait des complices
qui ont hébergé transportés et fournit
des armes au cerveau de cette attaque
les cerveaux justement de sont
actuellement inculpés au Mali les autres
sont en fuite un mandat d'arrêt
international a été émis à leur
rencontre aujourd'hui
l'attaque du 13 mars 2016 a fait 19
morts à Bassam et 33 blessés aujourd'hui
on a vu certains de ces rescapés ils
sont revenus au palais de justice pour
le verdict on écoute leurs réactions
soulager mais ça les résultats rien
passer mon fils a été traumatisé pendant
un an et demi jusqu'à l'heure là il a
encore traumatisé grâce à Dieu mon fils
a été épargné et le verdict a été rendu
un groupe de soulagement
ça mène une affaire au bout c'est pas
intense
mais tout n'est pas fait parce que les
grands responsables sont pas
les victimes qui se sont constituées
partie civils ont tout été indemnisées
les sommes allant du franc CFA
symbolique jusqu'à 50 millions de francs
CFA
voilà pour la Côte d'Ivoire on en vient
en haut deuxième épisode de notre série
consacrée au Soudan après l'économie
hier focus aujourd'hui sur le système
éducatif national en pleine crise les
chiffres sont parlants là-bas 7 millions
d'enfants sont privés d'écoles 12
millions d'autres ont eu une scolarité
perturbées manque de professeur de
moyens d'infrastructures crises à
répétition le pays vous l'avez compris
n'a plus les moyens de former sa
jeunesse reportage à cartoon il est
signé pour France 24 Clotilde
[Musique]
la situation ici il manque au moins
quatre professeurs pour gérer la plus de
ses élèves déscolarisés
ils viennent de différentes communautés
il y a de grosses différences de niveau
scolaire au même âge
qui n'ont jamais été en maternelle ou en
primaire
certains ont même jamais été scolarisés
générale au Soudan les fermetures
d'écoles dues au covid 19 et au coup
d'État ont aggravé la situation
d'abord le gouvernement doit garder les
écoles ouvertes rouvrir celles qui ne le
sont pas ils doivent payer les
enseignants et il faut en investissement
urgent pour l'éducation et sa
transformation autant sur la qualité de
l'enseignement que sur l'accès à
l'éducation
aujourd'hui près de 70% des enfants
soudanais de 10 ans ne savent pas lire
le Soudan du Sud voisin à lui était le
théâtre d'affrontement
inter-communautaire en quatre jours ils
ont fait 56 morts dans le nord de ce
pays tristement habitué à ce genre de
violence en tout selon l'ONU 166
victimes sont à déplorer depuis août des
tensions locales qui ont pris de
l'ampleur plusieurs provinces sont
désormais concernées Clément di Roma et
notre correspondant dans la région
depuis août dernier des affrontements au
nord du Soudan du Sud ont fait au moins
166 morts et des dizaines de milliers de
personnes déplacées selon les Nations
Unies le conflit a débuté dans l'état du
O'Neil suite à des tensions entre deux
meneurs de l'opposition du pays de la
communauté shiluk et l'autre de la
communauté Nuer de des plus grands
groupes ethniques du pays qui vivent au
bord du Nil les combats les meurtres les
enlèvements ou encore les pillages se
propagent maintenant aux régions et aux
communautés alentours comme dans l'état
du jongler plus au sud ou plus de 50
personnes sont mortes ces derniers jours
plusieurs ONG responsables locaux
multiplient les appels à l'aide envers
la communauté internationale et les
casques bleus le président kenyan a
appelé son homologue soudanais salvaquir
a ramené la paix dans cette partie du
pays et surtout à aider les humanitaires
qui ne peuvent toujours pas accéder à la
zone encore trop dangereuse alors
rappelons-le après l'accord de paix de
2018 qui a mis fin à 5 ans de guerre
civile plusieurs régions ont traversé
des épisodes violents déclencher la
plupart du temps par des vols de bétail
selon l'ONU 9 millions de Suds soudanés
ont toujours besoin d'aide humanitaire
soit 70% de la population
et c'est dans ce contexte de vivre
tension que le président sud soudanais
salvaquir va envoyer 750 militaires dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo une région n’en parle beaucoup sur
France 24 où les forces gouvernementales
et rebelles du M23 s'affrontent depuis
de longs mois une mission de maintien de
l'ordre c'est un nouveau coup dur porté
à la liberté de la presse en Algérie
Issan el-kadi directeur général entre
autres de radio M a été interpellé puis
mis sous les verrous l'arrestation a eu
lieu samedi 24 décembre samedi dernier
donc on apprend également dans la
journée que le journaliste a été
condamné dans une autre affaire à six
mois de prison écoutez ce qu'en pense il
est vice-président de la LADDH et de la
FIDH
ok chef d'incubation n'a été notifiée
là on se pose la question sur le prendre
sur le plan de la procédure judiciaire
ils sont hors télé hors temps un parti
par la réglementation d'une part de 2 à
ce qu'ils avaient un mandat d'arrêt
on le sait pas
troisièmement est-ce qu'ils ont un
mandat de perquisition on ne sait pas
aussi ce qu'il a dit c'est une affaire
qui qui ont monté contre ma personne et
prendre interface média une pratique
courante et je le répète aussi une
pratique courante depuis
l'avènement du mouvement Irak de la
révolution du hairac c'est une fois il
détecte une cible des personnes des
activistes des militants des droits
humains ou des opposants politiques il
les arrête et par la suite une
confection d'un dossier c'est une
violation très grave de la procédure et
du droit souvenez-vous que combien de
journaux ont été interdit de
paraître depuis le l'avènement du hairac
interface média à travers radio m et
Maghreb émergents restés les dernières
bougies qui allumaient
l'opinion nationale sur les vérités sur
les questions d'ordre politique
sociétale économique et de droit à la
fois la Constitution algérienne
l'article 80 48 dit clairement que la
liberté de la presse la liberté
d'opinion de penser et garantie par la
Constitution et que l'Algérie a ratifié
des conventions comme la le Pacte
international doit civique et politique
ces textes qui sont qui sont ratifiés
par l'Algérie et ne sont pas respectés
sur le terrain réellement et en fin de
compte on dit qu'il n'y a pas de liberté
de presse en Algérie
direction à présent le Gabon ou le
climat politique ne cesse de ce tendre
les élections générales c'est en 2023
l'année prochaine donc sur place pouvoir
et opposition on arrive toujours pas à
se mettre d'accord notamment sur la
composition de l'organe en charge du
scrutin d'où vous l'avez compris sauf
une mince affaire le reportage de nos
correspondants à Libreville alors siège
de Libreville le combat continue
forcément du parti d'opposition réagir
leur objectif obtenir avant la prise
d'ancienne de 2023 le renouvellement du
bureau du centre gabonais des élections
le CGE
[Musique]
un renouvellement qui se fait attendre
portant la Cour constitutionnelle avait
donné jusqu'au 15 décembre 2022 pour que
l'élection des nouveaux membres de ce
bureau soit organisés par l'opposant
François Donau ou bien le président de
réagir le gouvernement veut défier la
loi nous sommes au-delà de la cacophonie
mais d'un sabotage volontaire qui ne
veut pas nous permettre d'aller aux
élections de manière terrestre qui
n'existe pas et un gouvernement qui est
là-bas seul la liste électorale vous
comprenez le souci qu'à l'opposition de
la du ressenti d'une certaine fausseté
quelques kilomètres plus loin au Centre
d'études constitutionnelle de
l'université au mabango le professeur
teles
pour l'expert en droit public le statu
quo actuel au CGE pourrait pousser la
Cour constitutionnelle à le dissoudre la
Cour a déjà rendu deux décisions pour ce
qui concerne le renouvellement du cege à
coup sûr la cour n'attendra pas une
troisième décision de progression accusé
par l'opposition la majorité essentielle
tente de rassurer ce président d'un
parti proche du pouvoir et certains que
le gouvernement fera ce qu'il faut avant
les élections de 2023 bon je comprends
les inquiétudes des autres la région de
liste le séjour n'est pas changé il n'y
a pas encore
humaine est effective c'est sûr mais les
choses se passeront bien et pas en 2024
mais en 2023 une assurance qui est loin
de convaincre l'opposition gabonaise qui
redoute surtout une crise électorale
explosive en 2023 comme celle qui a vécu
le Gabon en 2016
cela faisait 18 mois qu'il ne s'était
pas serré dans les bras des familles
éthiopiennes séparées par la guerre aux
tigrée ont enfin pu se retrouver grâce à
la reprise des vols commerciaux entre
Addis-Abeba la capitale et mekelé des
larmes des embrassades avec bien sûr
dans un coin de la tête la volonté de
voir la paix entre rebelle et
gouvernement durée Laurent bertheycher
à peine arrivé sur le tarmac d'Addie
sabéba ils sont accueillis par leurs
proches et laisse éclater leur joie des
retrouvailles symboliques alors Kitty
open Airlines vient de rétablir la
liaison avec méqueler la capitale du
Tigré coupé du monde depuis 18 mois
devant l'aéroport des familles
s'apprêtant à faire le chemin inverse
sont elles aussi submergées par
l'émotion
quand j'ai appris la nouvelle je suis
tombé à genoux et j'ai fondu en larmes
je suis vraiment heureuse et j'espère
que la situation va continuer à
s'améliorer
tous les vols commerciaux vers le tigre
avait subitement été suspendu en juin
2021 au plus fort de la guerre entre le
gouvernement et les rebelles du TPLF de
nombreuses éthiopiens originaires de la
région s'étaient alors retrouvé bloqué à
Addis-Abeba un exil forcé qui touche
aujourd'hui à sa fin
j'étais venu ici pour voir ma fille qui
était sur le point d'accoucher j'étais
censé rester deux semaines mais tout a
fermé d'un coup ça fait déjà un an et
demi
lundi une délégation du gouvernement
s'est rendu à mekelé pour une première
visite officielle en deux ans après la
signature d'un accord de paix début
novembre la reprise des vols commerciaux
vers le tigre et représente aujourd'hui
un pas de plus vers un retour à la
normale en Éthiopie
fin de ce journal de l'Afrique rester
avec nous sur l'antenne de France 24
[Musique]